all right listen always always a good
start
you know I've done these shows so much
that I go yeah I know exactly where it
is shut up bull let me just say that
this country is so obsessed with health
that it makes me sick
okay we bombard ourselves with
information about health all the time
every newspaper has five pages about
health every week their questions like
is your prostate happy brand muffins
is - enough is one too many then that
final one Oh what are your feet telling
you about yourself they're not telling
me anything
they're my feet it's unbelievable what
we do it week week weeks if we don't
even know anything about health anymore
it's ridiculous you know we worry about
health as a result don't we everybody
thinks about it too much when you worry
about health you're not gonna be healthy
are you we worry about health so much
that we are the fattest group of people
in the world and if there was an
Olympics of fat we'd win the gold the
silver and the bronze because nobody
could fit in the stadium with us now we
know so much about health that we know
nothing okay
we know nothing case in point is milk
good or bad I rest my case
no you don't know and when I was a kid
you knew because there was only one kind
of milk moo cow milk and the cow
actually went Moo and you know what when
I was a kid you had to drink four
glasses of milk a day for who could do
that okay they're not enough cookies in
the universe
but now now we don't know if milks good
or bad because there's there's more milk
than we ever imagined you walk down that
aisle of the milk it goes on for weeks
1% 2% low-fat skim acidophilus milk
acidophilus milk are you insane that
belongs in the yogurt section milk
doesn't need acidophilus milk doesn't
need a friend lactose-intolerant milk
you can kiss my ass lactose intolerant
milk if you're lactose intolerant you
can't drink milk so what's in the carton
what's in the cart
get it away from my milk get it away
it's talking to my milk and making my
milk feel bad about itself soy milk I
was in Los Angeles and they asked me if
I wanted with my coffee half and half
regular skim or soy and my fist stopped
an inch from his nose I said you don't
ask anybody if they want soy milk soy
milk in English means tastes like crap
there's no such thing as soy milk it's
soy juice isn't it that's they squeezed
the beans and get the juice but nobody
would drink soy juice cuz when you say
it you actually get but there it is
there it is right in the milk section
right next to my milk and we know
there's no soy milk we're not stupid
because there's no soy titty is there
we know so much about health that in my
lifetime we destroyed water that's
almost impossible you know there was the
time and a lot of you are too young to
remember when water actually came to
your home and you could drink it but
then we decided we'd save money and we
wouldn't have our water clean so well so
we could buy the water at the
supermarket we said it's still
convenient I don't want the water coming
to my home I want to search for it much
like my ancestors did see you buy
bottles of spring water and purified
water and you think there's spring water
or purified water you're crazy you know
where it comes from there there's a
couple in Pittsburgh that sits in the
bathtub and fills those bottles up thank
you